code of the samurai code bats all the
same thing man ninja I have fallen a
little bit behind on the DC animated
properties but I'm working on it now and
let's talk about this thing when I first
heard about this I kind of [ __ ] my head
and went and then I heard that at least
some of the people who did Afro Samurai
which is a show I love I need to do that
as as either an animation junkie or why
it's awesome at some point down the road
we're working on it and sort of the
design and conceptual stages and then I
saw the first trailer was like maybe and
that first trailer was in Japanese and
then I saw the first trailer with the
English voice that I was like maybe not
so having now actually seen it it's
worth seeing that's worth seeing at
least once and the reason to see it is
the visuals the story is pretty big it's
pretty much exactly what you would think
it would be based off the pitch and you
know there's the voice work that I'll
come back to that
so and I've also gotten that pics but
you know let's talk about what works
visually this is really good most of the
time but I mean the design work on the
although re-imaginings of these Batman
characters as futile Japanese characters
you know as ninjas and samurais feudal
boards are you all these things and not
and not just Batman and villains like
Batman and villains and allies like a
ton of characters get this get this
redesigned treatment they look really
good like really cool so all that is Wow
love it so that's all really good the
action scenes are great they're
high-energy they are dynamic they're
intense they the hits feel big it's it's
really
all done action the non action scenes
are a little bit more iffy and that's
basically kind of a given with the
animation of parts they went with what
they did
I'm not sure that they actually still
call it this it's got a bit more
advanced than you know from when this
term first around but it's a bit like
cell shading so what we're looking at
our 3d models but they have kind of 2d
sort of what they just sort of painted
over to look like 2d cells and when
they're and when they're in series
motion and in action they look great
when characters are just standing around
talking they look awkward and often kind
of expressionless and I mean part of
that might might be a stylistic choice
but like unless they're doing like big
things you don't get a lot of emotion on
these faces I do think it is something
to do with the animation style because
I've seen that other times I've seen
this technique to use there's something
about subtle facial you know expressions
and and indicators of emotions and
thought processes that just don't read
well they look really they look like
puppets like marionette puppets so you
know so that that's not great the voice
work look some of its good they've got
taraf strong as Harley Quinn she's
always good most of the supporting casts
is decent
Batman is bland but he's also written
super bland
the writing in general actually isn't
very good now I'll point out at this
point I I watched the dubbed version of
the rental copy unfortunately didn't
have the the Japanese with subtitles
option I could I could see the subtitles
like from the original Japanese so I
could see how the translation was
different and I did that for a little
bit just to like get a get a sense of it
but
didn't have the option on the rental
copy dude to see it with the Japanese
voices and III that might have been
better it might have helped but the the
American voice is Batman yeah he's super
bland but you know the characters also
written to be that way he's he's not got
a lot going on he doesn't lean that
heavily into the setting the way
characters like the Joker or or honestly
be you know bein as a sumo wrestler the
you know the feudal lord versions of
penguin and to vase or whatever kind of
lean into all this Batman is just kind
of there through all of it which is a
little bit disappointing
then the Joker the Joker Tony Hale
voices the Joker Tony Hale of Arrested
Development and he sounds I'm gonna I'm
gonna say what he sounds like and then
I'm gonna explain what this is because
if you're not a theatre geek you might
not know this reference but it sounds
like rod from Avenue Q and if you want
to what Rob from Avenue Q sounds like
Avenue Q is a stage play you know a
Broadway show I don't know if it's still
on Broadway or not but it but it's a
stage musical and it's a riff on Sesame
Street it's Sesame Street for adults and
it's got you know puppets singing songs
like everyone's a little bit racist
that's sort of the big famous one the
character of rod is their riff on Bert
it's basically imagine if Bert from
Sesame Street was a closeted gay man
that's rod and that's what this Joker
sounds like and he just didn't work for
me
very well again not helped by the
dialogue I have to wonder if they were
it would the way that the translation
was done because this seemed a lot more
pronounced you know because like I said
I did look at the the subtitles
translated directly from the Japanese
just to compare
and I did get the sense that this this
was a much stronger vibe in the the
dubbed version versus the subtitles
which is I feel like they really leaned
into the perceived kam penis of like old
kung fu movies like 90s era anime you
know it seems like every other line is a
character just saying another
character's name with a question mark at
the end of it Joker Batman two-face
Harley Quinn like that's the caliber of
writing on display in the dub and I it's
so prevalent that I have to think
somebody at some level thought it was
funny they thought like look this thing
is so cheesy cuz it is it's very
over-the-top anime cheesy they decided
to lean into the Western perception of
just how cheesy that is the problem is
that stuff really only works if you
don't treat it like it's a joke like I
do not say there aren't joke moments
there are but you you can't treat the
whole thing like it's a joke I mean to
make the comparison again you know Afro
Samurai is preposterous and ridiculous
and cheesy as hell but it's also treated
serious which is part of why it's
awesome so you know I watch them like
this where it feels like the translation
is really leaning on the are remember
those old bad dubbed kung fu movies
where the the dialogue was all
repetitive and redundant kinda stupid
will do that like don't and if they
weren't trying to do that then they were
just half-assing the Trant the
translation for the for the dub so I
don't know which is the case I don't
know which is worse the end result I
can't tell the difference between one or
the other so if the bad result either
way and so you know this is cheesy fun
as I said so I mean you've got samurais
with Joker masks you've got buildings
transforming into giant robots and those
robots then proceeding to smack
each other around yes that is all there
but that stuff is best when it's not
treated like a uh how crazy is this
which is how Westerners read dubbing or
translating this stuff tend to treat it
and it's not as interesting it's not as
fun it's just not as entertaining when
that kind of thing happens and I and I
really feel like it did with the with
the Dublin I feel like it does a
disservice to them because like I said
visually the movies a lot of fun and I
feel like you could have been a lot more
fun if the the translation on the dub
wasn't making fun of it as it went along
or at least didn't feel like it did now
that said I don't wanna I don't want to
oversell you know taking away the the
voice and translation issues cuz there's
some weird things going on anyways I'm
not sure how much it added overall to
have this be a time displacement story
of Batman and all of his villains being
sent to the past as opposed to just
doing it straight as an Elseworlds
and having them just be there and I you
know I I do see like plot wise the way
that decision impacts things but at the
end of the day I don't think it actually
adds much at all so I'm not entirely
sure why they chose to do that I mean
I'll give credit for one thing there's a
really genuinely funny moment and again
funny because there aren't any lines
dubbed in and it's just allowed to
happen and be funny where Batman is
finds himself in the middle of this
funeral Japanese village and he goes to
hook shot away and he looks up and
realizes there's no skyscrapers the
buildings are not tall enough for him to
just hook and zipline away it's you know
completely away from where anybody can
can see him or grab him and that's a
silent moment it's conveyed through the
visuals and that's funny but you know
there are little moments like that but I
just I feel like it might have just been
more fun to just really lean into the
Elseworlds nature of this I mean
look at it already this doesn't look
like it's in keeping with continuity why
open up that possibility by having it be
a time travel story just do a straight
up else world so I'm not entirely sure
why that decision was made and there
were a lot of nitpicky things that that
I could go and I'll just mention two one
is that there's a segment in the middle
dealing with the Joker where the
animation style changes and it's kind of
interesting but I don't know what
purpose is served not just the animation
shift but like the scene in and of
itself I don't know what purpose is
served I have to wonder if that's
something that was inserted to get this
thing to eat to the runtime they needed
except this is an 85 minute runtime
normally these things are 75 so this
thing is already running long compared
to what usually goes on with the DC
animated films so the other nitpick and
this is a true legitimate nitpick they
keep calling apes monkeys and it drives
me nuts and wouldn't drive me nuts
except gorilla grodd doesn't - he says
his army of monkeys they're not monkeys
they're Apes none of them have tales
like that guy you want to talk about a
setup for a joke it should have been
everyone else saying monkeys and he gets
pissed and yells at them saying they're
Apes
hey I just bugged me but I mean at this
point I probably sound really down on
the thing because I've been going
through the stuff that doesn't really
work in unfortunately if you're gonna
count it up there is more stuff that I
feel doesn't work then stuff that does
but I'm gonna come back to one of the
first things I said I do think it's
still worth watching for the visuals
alone it is visually a lot of fun it is
inventive it's got nifty designs it's
got cool action the question is whether
or not that's enough for you and for me
outside of the novelty of it and seeing
it the ones that's not enough like my
favorites of these DC animated films I
buy I want to watch again I'm never
gonna need to see this again I don't
work right seeing it you know to say
that I've seen
be like you know there's some cool stuff
there but I don't ever need to see that
one again so those are my thoughts on
batman ninja have you seen it what do
you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it you know
the stuff that you can do like and
subscribe and support me on patreon by
t-shirt follow me on Twitter send me an
email send me stuff with the mail I've
got a Bo box the links for all that
stuff and probably more that I didn't
even mention is all done in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]